Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my gosh, I just noticed the main screen, like...
I just noticed it.
Oh my god, why is my chat always dead?
Every time I swap, guys, the loop is starting.
The bark...
The negative bark loop feedback is starting already.
Um, okay.
He knows I'm streaming, so he's not barking right now.
Thank god.
He has... that DrakeyAmberDoge has, like, learned, like, when I'm streaming and that means do not disturb me.
Do not- Today is not the right time right now.
Chikorii, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
What's that, DokiBeard?
Are you starving?
Yeah, I'm hungry, too.
Consuming my food menu, by the way.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, today I, like, ordered- today I, um...
I, uh, I didn't eat lunch yet.
Um, well, it's technically gonna be dinner soon, too, because I was, you know, like I said, yesterday, uh, okay, you might hear the dog- you might hear the Toy Poodle barking in the background because I can't stop her, obviously, like, she's not my dog.
But, like, when I- you guys caught the last stream, um, I was so tired for some reason, like, yesterday I was so fucking tired.
I, like, took multiple naps yesterday and, like, um, I was supposed to get some work done and I was like, I'm gonna sleep.
I'm gonna fucking sleep and take a nap, take, like, a three-hour nap, and I ended up waking up at, like, 11 a.m.
And I was like, oh fuck, like, because I was like, that was so much to do!
Um, but after this stream, I still have a lot to do.
So, like, basically, I got up, I had to go straight to work because- and then, like, for some reason my Apex settings reset itself, so I had to take some time to fix my Apex settings.
I got almost everything except for Taco Aim.
Taco Aim was the only thing I wasn't able to, like, fix and I had to fix it during the game.
So, um, and my Apex settings reset itself, so I had to do and fix that.
And then I had to, like, upload my waiting room because I forgot I was gonna upload it after my nap, but my nap ended up being at 11 a.m.
So I ended up not uploading it.
So I ended up uploading my waiting room, um, super last minute, you know, like an hour before the tournament was supposed to start.
And then the thing is, like, and then I had, like, other work stuff to do, so I had to do, like, I was supposed to upload my Fortnite video today, but then, like, I didn't realize, and I think my manager didn't realize, but we had no thumbnail for that video.
Because my manager was like, all right, make sure you upload the video, like, at four.
And I was like, yeah, of course.
Um, but like, uh, I was gonna, I was uploading it after the tournament and I was like, wait, I have no thumbnail for this.
Like, we have everything done but a thumbnail.
Like, and then, um, and so then I was like, sorry, that's the toy poodle.
So then I was like, oh, what the fuck do I do?
I was like, oh, well, my manager's asleep.
So I was like, I have no thumbnail.
What do I do?
So, like, it's not my fault.
I literally have no thumbnail.
Like, I don't know what to do.
So, like, I messaged, like, one of our editors and was like, can you make a clickbait thumbnail?
Like, um, so we're gonna see, like, we're gonna see how that goes.
Uh, so they said they can get to me, um, in, like, a bit.
Um, but yeah, and then after, and then the Fortnite thing and then, you know, we had, oh my god, that custom was so it was, oh my god, it was such a mess.
Like,
I think they, I think they just used, like, public apex lobbies and stuff.
It was rough.
It was so, I think, like, for me, my vibes were, like, it kept getting, like, you know how, like, you're trying to keep, like, the same vibe throughout?
It was so hard to keep the same vibe when, like, you know, it, there were always interruptions and everything.
So I was just, like, like, like, it threw off my vibe.
Like, it kept throwing it off.
It didn't help that I DC'd too, like, yeah, I feel a lot better about my, my custom.
I was talking to, like, one of my friends about it who participated.
Uh, well, they didn't participate in this one.
Um, but they were saying that, like, oh, yeah, no, you're, there was no issues with your custom.
But this one, there was, like, I, they were, like, yeah, we heard, like, a lot of people were complaining about it because, like, it was, um, it was, like, um, people were complaining about it because, you know, it was, there was, like, so much, like,
stuff.
I think it's the rules.
I think, because, like, I knew that, like, um, when you have, like, legend lock rules, when you have rules that were, like, based off of, like, lot, like, you gotta pick specific legends, someone's gonna fuck it up.
Like, because there's, there's 60 people.
There's 60 people and, like, um, you do not expect them to read the rules.
Like, so, the fact that we had to restart every game, every fucking game because at least one team just forgot to pick the legend because we don't know when it's gonna start, too.
That's the thing.
So, like, yeah, my vibes were, like, so thrown off when we had to restart, like, every fucking game.
We also got really unlucky in some games.
Like, you know, my, me DCing and, uh, I still had fun.
I just wish that, like, I just wish it didn't, like, I wish, like, we didn't have to restart every match, too.
Uh, that's the only thing, like, that, like, uh, bothered me, that we have to restart every game.
And then when you're restarting a game, you have to wait in between restarting, too.
So that was, like, super annoying for me.
And I usually don't get annoyed very much when it comes to, like, stuff like this.
But, like, when it was, like, every fucking game, I was like, oh my god.
Oh, put me out of my misery.
I heard the custom had, um, uh, yeah, it ruined the pacing.
The custom had a lot of issues that came up, especially getting, like, participants and stuff, because, like, each team was supposed to have one content creator, one pro, and one VTuber, but some teams ended up having, like, two V, like, two pros and stuff and everything.
So, like, the balancing was, like, super off in general, uh, because of it.
Um, even though it was, like, at first they were like, oh, yeah, like, this is gonna be how the balancing goes.
Um, was there one team?
I think there was one team with two pros and a, um, and a challenger circuit player.
Uh, I know, like, one team had, like, two pros and challenger circuit.
So it was just, like, it was just weird balancing in general.
Um, which is, like, like, I've had issues with that, too.
Balancing is very, very hard, um, and everything.
So, like, I get that.
I get that, though.
Like, I get, like, uh, how hard it is to do balancing and stuff.
And a lot of people were, like, dropping last minute to, uh, dropping out, um, at last minute.
Because I know there was, like, teams that literally got a replacement.
Teams that had replacements given to them.
Um, five minutes after it was supposed to start.
Like, you know, like, the customer was supposed to start at 1 p.m.
And then, like, they had a replacement given to them, like, at 1.05.
So, um, so, like, it was, like, super fucking rough for some, um, people.
So, yeah.
Yeah, because, like, um, because, like, I know, like, the custom itself wasn't, like, officially.
By the way, I found out I wasn't even supposed to announce I was gonna be part of this custom.
Like, we were supposed to, uh, we were supposed to, like, wait until an official announcement came out and then we talk about it.
I didn't know that because I didn't pay it.
I didn't, like, there was no paying for it.
Um, but somebody, I realized somebody asked about it.
Please hold off until we make an official announcement, but then the official announcement was today.
I wasn't gonna...
I was gonna... I wasn't gonna wait until today to post my schedule.
Like,
the official announcement was today.
Like, I can't wait until today to post my fucking schedule.
Like...
So, yeah, so I was just like, wait, what?
Um, yeah, they announced it today.
Yeah, the custom was today and then, and then, um, um, and then, um, and then, you know, they announced it today.
Yeah, because, like, people, you see, people were, like, dropping out a lot.
So people had to, like, find players, like, other players.
Um, they have to find other players to replace them.
So they have to, they waited until today to post out the schedule and, like, post up the official announcement.
And even when the official announcement was made, people were still dropping out.
I was just like, oh my god, I feel so bad.
Like, they're like, these people are gonna be in it.
And then people were still dropping out.
Also need to check what time my food's gonna be here.
So I'm gonna be, give me a sec, guys, uh, 555.
Okay, guys, 555.
Yeah, I feel so, yeah, it was, there's just a lot.
Like, I knew, as somebody that organized it, I know it's, like, really, like, you know, it's really difficult to organize, like, coordinate 60 people to be there.
Um, and everything.
Um, uh, oh, yeah, you know what was funny?
I was re-watching, okay, so you guys know how I was in Block, for those who don't know, I was in Block Wars, the Minecraft Twitch Rivals, uh, two days ago, and I was streaming on Twitch.
And, you know, I was, like, watching other POVs because I was curious.
I was curious what they were gonna say about me.
And then people were, like, like, the team we fought, the enemy team we fought, uh, during the last game.
They were, like, they were basically, like, shit-talking about our block skins.
And they were, like, my, like, I hate those block skins, those stupid try-hards.
And then, like, the thing is, when you, like, swap to my POV or Gumi's POV, we were just, like, you know what would be funny?
What if we, like, like, our POV, my POV was literally was just, like, oh, man, it'd be so fucking funny if we just swapped the block skins.
Oh my god, I'll be fucking hilarious, like,
like, like, they're, like, people are, like, I can't believe they're trying this hard.
And then, and then the thing is, if you cut back to my POV, we were, like, the least try-hards in the entire team.
Like, me, Gumi, and SK were literally just fucking around and everything.
And then the casters, I think, were, like, oh my god, that was insane tech from Aqua.
Like, wow, swapping to block skins, what an insane tech that they just, like, thought of to, like, have an advantage to the other teams.
And then, like, literally us, we're, like, it'd be so fucking funny, like,
it's, like, it'd be so silly if we did that.
Like, yeah, it was my idea, but I did not think, like, swapping to block skins actually helped us.
I just thought it was fucking funny.
Um Um and then, like, yeah, so I was watching it.
I just thought that was so silly because literally our actual Minecraft players were trying so fucking hard and then I was just, like, yay!
Oh my god, we should do this.
Like, let's all swap to Sonic characters and start role-playing.
Woo!
Oh, so I got a call.
Is it about my food?
Give me a sec.
I got- oh, wait.
No, they hanged up.
Never mind.
I don't know.
Also, the- yes!
Okay, before we start the game, did you guys see the Pac-Man movie?
The Pac-Man, um, episode short trailer?
That shit was fucking wild.
I was watching, um, it popped up on my Twitter feed.
You know, the one where, um, oh, I found them.
So, you know how they're making, like, video game, like, episode adaptations?
And, like, um, one- I- this is the Pac-Man one.
I was not- I was like, what?
Like...
Yeah, so...
So they're making, like, an anthology series.
Like, um, what was it?
Um, Love Robots- Love Deaf Robots.
I don't know.
Robots Deaf Love or whatever.
So, um, so there's one for Pac-Man.
It's basically like that, but for video games.
And then it's called Secret Level.
Yeah, Concord is in it, too.
And apparently the Concord episodes were supposed to be with DLC characters.
And the Pac-Man one, I was like, what the fuck?
That's Pac-Man?
Yeah, like, that- that's literally, like, I'm just- I'm so confused.
I'm so fucking confused.
Also, okay, so...
Flappy Dragoons.
What is Flappy Dragoons?
Well, that's easy.
It's basically a fan game that you Dragoons have made for me.
Um, let me put- let me click, uh, let me pin the- pin in the chat.
Uh, down the game I'm playing.
All right.
So this is the game I'm playing- gonna be playing right now.
It's basically like Flappy Birds.
But like, what if like, you know, instead of birds, like, you know, instead of like, you know, the actual Flappy Bird that's apparently copyrighted, it's Dragoons.
I love the pixel art, though.
That's so cute.
I love the long ass necks that we all have, except for this guy right here, this guy.
Um, yeah, it's so cute.
Does anyone know what the streamer mode means?
I don't know what it means.
What is- what does it mean when I put it on streamer mode?
Oh my god, it could be a tomato.
What's fancy?
Oh my god, fancy!
Okay, legoon, egg.
He's just there.
Like, does he even flap?
Oh, it prevents you from being demonetized?
Oh, okay.
All right, I won't turn it off.
Well, there's egg.
What's the nerd?
Fucking nerd.
Um, ink bird.
Whoa.
Legs.
What is it?
Tired, moon, baseball.
Oh my god, the skins are so cute!
Oh, OG Doki Bird!
Oh my god, croaky.
Wait, I need to play as croaky.
Okay.
But I believe this is the credits, right?
Oh my god, huge shout out to all the- all the people who worked on this.
Kaz!
Wait, I know this guy!
I also know Johnny Lacone, Aphelion, Jono.
Oh my god, there's so many people that worked on it.
Music.
No one.
Wait, oh, okay.
I was like, oh, main theme.
Right here.
We back from the heist.
Oh my god, you guys made all the music, too!
My- oh, I remember you guys!
Testers.
Your laugh cracks me up, Doki.
Merry Christmas, everyone!
Merry Christmas!
JT, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, there's localization, too!
Wait, you guys localized it?
Oh my god, that's so cute!
That's actually so cute that you guys localized it.
Oh my god.
Hey, that's me!
I'm Doki Bird!
Support me right here!
We're almost at 800k subscribers.
It's crazy to think about.
I know I said like, oh, yeah, maybe we'll hit a million.
I knew we weren't gonna hit a million by the end of the year.
That was like actual goals, never goals that was like a little bit too- too ambitious, you know?
All right, it's time.
Let's play Flappy Dragoon.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I figured it out.
Guys, it's been a while since I- I like how- I like how it's not even me.
It's just some like random crow.
Okay, I'm gonna submit this.
Okay.
Guys, look at that, guys.
Oh my- what the fuck?
How?
Guys, look, I'm on the leaderboard!
Look at that!
I'm on the fucking leaderboard!
Let's go!
I knew I was better.
All right, let's see.
Let's do the default.
All right.
Oh, it's so cute!
It's like...
Oh, okay, we're not hitting the- Okay.
We're not hitting- okay.
No, we don't yet.
We're definitely not hitting the fucking...
Um, ten thousand whatever.
God damn it.
Why is this so hard?
Okay.
All right.
I forgot how hard Flappy Bird was.
I actually had Flappy Bird on my phone.
I think if I- Oh my god.
I think I still have it on my phone because I never deleted it too.
That shit's like worth like thousands of dollars.
When people used to sell it on their phone.
Why?
Why is this so hard?
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's the indent.
Okay.
It's just the hole is so tiny!
Okay, we're gonna try and get at least ten.
All right, you guys think you're better?
Boot up the game right now.
Wait, guys, can I buy this game off you guys and then we put it on Steam?
Yoink mine now.
Yoink!
Oh, this would be like created by the Doki Bird team and then it'll be like Doki Bird, Doki Bird, Doki Bird, Doki- Wait, I can literally- wait, because it's my face, it's my property.
I don't- technically I don't have to pay you guys.
Do you think you made this?
I made this.
It's literally my- Yoink, put it on.
Yoink, put it on Steam.
Technically, it's mine.
I'm joking though, but I won't- I don't- Honestly, I'm so open to putting this on Steam.
And like have you guys like develop more to it, like what is there to develop more for in terms of Flappy Bird though?
What the- what- I mean, technically, the Flappy Bird- Technically, if you think about it, I can't get past one point.
The Flappy Bird, uh, the Flappy Bird, uh, copyright has expi- I- how do I get past level one point?
Um...
Okay, here we go.
Wait, audio...
Techni- uh...
Technica?
Thank you for the super chat, Anton!
Thank you, thank you!
We'll strip the skins off our hides in this game turn- wait, what did you use for it?
What's audio tech- Technica?
Technica?
What is that?
What does it do?
Well, what does that do?
Audio managed- we use something else.
We will remake it.
Wait, there's like- there's more than one map?
Oh my god, come on, I just need 10.
Give me 10 points!
Oh my god.
Remake it and I'll even have recording.
I'll even record it.
Like, I'll be like, remake it now for free.
Obviously not for free.
No, I'd be so down!
I've always wanted to release games on Steam.
I think it'll be so- I've been like, looking into like, making games again.
Or not making, but like, producing games again.
And like, um, I think- oh my god, please.
And like, I think it'll be really cool if we could like, uh, work on this and like, I could pay you guys to remake it for Steam.
And then we can add like, different levels, different cosmetics, and like, have like, uh, recordings and stuff like that.
I think it'll be really cute.
All right, nice.
And then we can have like, actual like, uh, leaderboards.
Like, uh, like, I'm pretty sure this is like, local.
This has to be a local leaderboard.
Um, like, it's not like, synced to anything online.
So I think it'd be really cool if we could make it so that we can have like, actual world leaderboards.
And see how far people will do.
Oh my god, I'm so bad at- Ah!
Okay.
Uh, all right, that's fine.
All right, one.
My goal is ten.
Okay, two.
Are you serious?
It's the skin.
It's the fucking skin.
I refuse to believe it's- it's me.
I like how the egg has zero sound effects.
Memorable man, thank you for the 50 gifted shits!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh my god, please.
I can't believe it.
Okay, it's the skin.
It's the skin.
It's 100% the skin.
What if we do- okay, the tomato.
Wait, why is the tomato like, sci-fi?
Why is- Okay.
I like how the- I like how his sound effects is just sci-fi.
Oh, you guys think you're better?
Oh, yeah, what's your highest score right now?
Are you playing along?
There's no way.
It's the hitbox.
It's so bad.
Oh my god, get me out of this map.
I don't want to be in this area anymore.
Okay, all right, let's- it's the map, guys.
It's- it's actually the map.
It's- I need to like- What's the- what's kinako?
What is that?
Okay, it's the map.
If I do this, we'll be fine.
If I do traditional...
If I- okay, never mind.
Okay, it's- it's the skin, guys.
It's the skin.
It's not- it's not the- it's not- it's not me.
Uh...
Maybe as a nerd, I'll do better.
I'll try so hard as a nerd.
Okay.
Okay, my glasses were off.
Okay, okay.
Okay, one.
I'm locking in.
Okay, I'm not locking in now.
I'm- it's just because I'm hungry, chat.
I'm just- Guys, I haven't eaten yet.
Guys, I'm just- oh my god, I'm so hungry.
Okay, one, two, three.
Fucking- okay.
I'm getting better though.
I'm figuring it out.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Oh my god, okay.
I can do it.
One.
Okay.
One, two- please!
I got the score!
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Seven, eight, nine.
Okay.
Oh my god, no, it's over.
Oh my god.
I wish there was an easier way to restart.
Guys!
I need you to restart!
I need an easier way to restart!
As an aspiring game dev, I'd like to know what game engine this was made in.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, Dragoons, what game engine was it?
Oh, is it R?
Oh my god, it was R.
Guys, that's not intuitive.
You didn't Doki proof this.
Guys, you didn't Doki proof it.
If you had Doki proofed it, you would have been press R.
Oh my god.
I would do an Akasupa if you passed.
Okay, I'm locking in.
I'm locking in.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, one, two, three, four.
Ah, I keep going too high!
Oh my god.
Guys, if the trees were yellow, I would have made it.
One, two...
Oh my god, come on!
What if I just fly above it?
Oh, okay, there's... I can't.
Sorry, the sky hates me too.
Six.
Yeah.
No, I keep going too high!
I need to thread the needle.
It's easier to be low.
What?
How is that a hitbox?
Okay, I figured out the strat.
It's the skin.
It's the skin, but I figured it out.
I need a new skin.
I'm so tired.
Okay.
Guys, what's the meta?
Guys, what skin is the meta?
Guys?
I need to know.
Wait, ojidoki is meta?
Is it the crow?
Oh, is the crow actually meta?
Okay, okay.
Is fancy actually... okay.
I can definitely tell fancy is not the meta.
Wait, different skins actually have different hitboxes?
Wait, who is the smallest?
It's not her.
It's definitely not.
Oh my god, my legs is gonna touch something.
What would be the smallest?
I guess default, right?
Because there's no way it's the egg.
Okay, I think default is the smallest.
Okay, locked in.
Oh my god.
Okay, locked in for real.
Okay, one, two, three, four, five.
Okay.
Come on, I just need 20.
Okay, one, two...
Oh, this is so difficult.
It's only been 30 minutes.
I don't understand.
Okay, three, five, six.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I can't, I can't.
This has to be... this has to be harder than Flappy Birds.
There's no way.
If I could tap my screen, it'd be so over.
If I could tap my phone, if I could be like... if I tap my screen, I'd do better.
Oh my god, please.
I just want to hit 20.
Bro, it does not... I feel like I've been playing this game for like 20 years already.
Okay, one.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Oh
my god.
Three, four, five, six.
I swear, I swear to god.
Where does the top tree come from?
How does the tree grow like that?
I'm getting unimmersed.
It's because of my immersion.
It's a lack of immersion.
Yeah, if you... if you fucking tap a dragoon, you crush his entire skull.
I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't.
Oh, I'm gonna use my mouse.
Oh, maybe it's because I'm not using my mouse.
Oh my god, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what I use.
I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't even get to 10.
One, two, three.
Guys, it's a lot harder than you think.
Five, six.
When's my food gonna get here?
When's my food getting here?
Okay, $5.59.
Guys...
Guys, I swear this is a lot harder than it looks.
Guys, I'm not bad.
I swear.
Oh my god.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Donate, thank you for the super chat.
Maybe he should have went with dead.
Oh my god.
Why is it so hard keeping it dead?
Guys, this should... you should... guys, I think you guys should lower the difficult.
Next patch note, I think you should have a doki bird mode and then like... and then like...
make the hitbox like... you should make a mode that's like only for doki bird and then you gotta give me the pass that you can only unlock via password.
And then like... and then mix my hitbox like one pixel.
Like I want to be like those... like what was it?
Those like...
um, Geometry Dash cheaters where like you can have a cheat in Geometry Dash.
Where like the hit... there's like no hitbox.
But as long as you tap in time, like people will think you're doing it correctly.
I want to be that guy.
Was it that?
I saw... I saw a video.
I saw a video of like, um, an OC.
I don't know, the Geometry Dash pro that got caught for cheating because all he did was he disabled...
he disabled the hitbox on Geometry Dash and then like, um, and all he did was just because there's like a camera on his hand too.
And he just like made sure to like, uh, to tap to the... to the sync of his... of his... of his, uh, jumps.
So we gotta do that too.
As long as you give me a password that only I can access and then like... wait, maybe I can access the files.
Hahaha!
Delete my hitbox.
That's all I want.
Someone develop a cheat... a cheat engine for this game.
Like how there's cheat engines for CSGO.
Someone develop one for Flappy Dragoon.
And I'll download it.
I don't care if you put like, um...
I don't care if you put like, spyware.
As long as it works, it's fine.
Oh
my god, he always just jumps.
I never get to... I never get to end.
Okay.
Someone was like, which is worse, Flappy Dragoon or RockSuki?
RockSuki, at least I made fucking progress.
Like...
I don't think I'll ever... I can't even make progress in this game!
Oh my
god.
Oh my god!
There's no improvement!
There's actually no improvement!
Okay, I'm locking in.
I'm actually gonna lock in.
Please never cry.
Okay.
Like some of these hitboxes are actually bullshit.
Oh my god!
Please, I just won.
I won 10.
I won 10!
Okay.
I'm always so close.
I think my favorite panel from Queen Never Cry is just...
Like, I never even read the... Okay, I don't know if you guys read the first chapter of that, uh...
Webtoon, but it's so fucking wild.
Like...
It's actually so wild.
Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
I need to shut the fuck up.
New record though, new record!
I'm actually getting better.
Oh my god, everyone tells me.
No!
It's a ping.
John, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry.
It took me four hours to get a score of 21.
I don't have four hours.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Almost there.
Thank you for the five gifts and chips.
Thank you.
Bro, this game is so hard!
Like, why is this Flappy Bird is easier than this?
I swear, I think you should add yellow paint.
Honestly, if there was yellow paint, it would've been over.
It would've been over.
It's okay.
Five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
God!
Pay up!
Pay the fuck up!
Oh my God!
Who said it took four hours?
Get fucked, John!
It took me 30 minutes!
Get fucking shit on!
I know you gave me money, but like, you gave me money to motivate me, but get your fucking shit on!
Four hours, 30 minutes for me!
Thank you for the aqua, aqua, aqua soup!
Thank you, thank you.
Parappa, thank you for the five gifts and chips.
Mike, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
The true game.
I think my food's almost here.
Give me a sec.
Oh shit!
Okay, guys, I'm gonna get my food.
I'll be right back.
I'm here.
I'm here now.
Alright.
Oh my God.
I locked the fucking... I'm gonna beat that score.
I'm gonna beat it.
I'm gonna fucking beat it.
Oh wait, my food.
Not now, I realized.
I'm back!
I got my food!
I'm super excited.
I'm so fucking hungry.
Holy shit.
I'm really fucking hungry right now.
But no, we're gonna beat the score first.
I think I've, like, figured it out.
I'm, like, so motivated now.
I won't eat until I beat it.
Okay, maybe...
Second ice soup arc is gonna be crazy!
Zacona, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, you thought I wouldn't make it.
You thought I couldn't get it.
It's, like, K-O-O... What's it called?
It's, like, the bee skewers.
The koo bee... I can't pronounce it.
It's so good, though.
What is it called?
The koo... K-O-O-B...
I don't know how to pronounce it.
I also don't know how to spell it.
I don't know how...
Well, it's not skewer.
It's not skewer, sorry.
It's, like... Oh, koo bee day.
Yes, yes, koo bee day!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I might be butchering it.
It's so good.
I'm, like, obsessed with, like, Persian food.
Um...
Because it's, like, it's actually, like...
It's... Oh, my God.
Like, I don't know.
The softness of the meat itself is just...
It's just a whole other world.
The texture.
I just love the texture.
It's just basically, like, grounded beef.
Um, it's very... And then with the rice, like, um...
With the special rice that comes with it.
Because it has, like, a yellow patch.
It's, like, yellowed rice.
But I don't know exactly what it is...
What the... I don't know exactly what...
The taste of it is.
Um... Oh, wait.
Is that Iranian?
I thought it was Persian.
Because some Persian restaurants serve it, too.
I didn't realize it was Iranian.
I thought it was Persian.
Um, because, like, some...
Wait, isn't it...
Wait, is Iran...
Iranian is... Okay, now...
Okay, now I'm, like...
Guys, I don't know my geography.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so...
I thought... I'm so sorry.
I didn't know it's the same.
I don't know my geography.
But it's so good.
What kind of rice is it, too?
I don't even know what rice it is.
But it's, like, a yellow patch.
If you've never had Persian food, you guys gotta try it.
Especially with the grounded beef.
It's... Oh, my God.
Like, I... I have it, like, once every...
Every couple of weeks.
There's, like, so much food.
Or, like, I try...
Oh, guys, I...
I made spaghetti... I made spaghetti yesterday.
It was so good that I made it twice.
Wait, wait, let me log in real fast.
Okay, I need to show you guys a picture.
Um...
Because I sent it to my friend because I was so proud of myself.
Because I haven't cooked food in a long-ass time.
So, like, I was so proud of myself.
Because I got pots and pans!
Wait, I need to show you guys.
I made spaghetti.
And I made it, like, twice.
Because I was so proud... Because it was so good.
So I made it again.
My bacon expired.
But, like, um...
I used spam instead.
So...
Guys, look!
It's, like, I put, like...
I used, like, those...
It was, like, eggs with cheese.
I had, like, fancy cheese that I bought from Whole Foods.
And then, um...
I put spam in it.
And it was so good.
Oh my god.
And I made it twice yesterday.
I, like, literally made it.
It's, like, a fucking mishmash of, like, different things.
And it's not a paper plate!
What do you mean by...
It was so good.
And there's scrambled eggs, too.
And...
And everything.
It was... Oh my god.
I was so... Oh my god.
It was so good that I actually made it twice.
Because I was like, I want to eat this again.
Yeah, I can cook!
Thank you for the super chat.
It's also spaghetti.
But, no, I can actually cook.
I can't bake.
Because baking, you actually need to be, like, super precise with measurements.
But I can cook meals.
The issue is that...
I don't normally cook meals.
Because, like, when you live alone...
It's such a hassle to make something nice for yourself.
And then you have to clean everything afterwards.
Like, I still haven't cleaned...
Okay.
Um...
Okay, you guys can judge me for this.
I...
Also, another reason why I was like, I'm going to make it again.
Was because I didn't really want to clean my pan.
Right then.
So I was like, well, I'll just reuse it.
Because, um...
I literally just used it today.
Like, at lunch time.
So I can reuse it during dinner.
So...
And then I'll clean it after.
Because, like...
I technically don't need to clean it yet.
And there's no mold yet!
It's literally the same day!
And it's the same day!
So, like...
I was just like...
Well, technically...
Because it's only been, like, you know, a few...
Like, a couple of hours.
Um, I don't have...
I can literally reuse the...
The pan!
So, like...
The pan where I mixed everything together.
Because technically, it's the...
It's the same day!
Only a couple of hours have passed!
So...
No...
No, no, I'm fine.
It's been 24 hours.
Nothing has happened!
Nothing!
See?
You can't judge me!
Because you would do the same thing!
You would've done the same thing!
But I was super proud of myself.
Because I haven't cooked in a long time.
And I made spaghetti.
I went to Whole Foods and bought cheese.
I didn't buy anything else in Whole Foods.
Because it's Whole Foods.
Like...
I was like...
It was very expensive cheese.
Because I was like, you know what?
I want some expensive cheese.
I will wash it.
And then I reused the plate, too.
Because I was like, well...
Technically, like...
I did reuse the fork.
I used a different fork, though.
Actually, no.
I washed the fork.
I washed the fork, but I didn't wash the plate.
Because I was like, well, technically...
It's the same plate which I ate the last spaghetti.
So, like...
It's like leftovers.
I washed the fork.
If anything, I washed the fork.
I just didn't wash the plate.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Fifteen.
What was my rate?
I stopped locking in.
Guys, I was just trying to...
I was very environmentally conscious, guys.
I was just trying to save the environment.
Hey, Doki.
I also get the cooking not wanting to clean.
See?
Validation.
Thank you for enabling me.
Salty.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
See?
Thank you for being part of my echo chamber.
I'm like so down to like...
Help you guys like...
Fun to improve this game.
Because I think we could definitely make it even better.
With like different cosmetics.
Different levels.
More songs.
Different game modes.
And everything.
A global... I think a global...
Multiplayer leaderboard would be like...
Fun.
Okay, what the fuck is power- Oh yeah, power-ups!
You're right.
We could technically add power-ups.
Like extra life.
If you like...
You get enough points in...
And then you can go to the shop...
And buy like extra lives and stuff.
Like pay to win.
We love pay to win.
Skill- What the- What is battle royale?
Whoever can last the longest in Flappy Dragoon.
Okay.
God damn it.
Okay, my goal before end stream.
Oh no, not the crypto- Did you see the Hawktua girl made a crypto meme cryptocurrency and people got so mad at her because like...
It lost like 80% of its value within a day.
I'm like, why the fuck did you invest in that?
It was obviously a rug pull.
She's so smart.
She's so business smart.
Like...
She sold...
She sold out so hard.
She knew her fucking meme is not eternal.
It's like, I don't even know how the fuck that meme lasted as long as it did.
She knew she's gonna be like, fade into obscurity very fast.
So she cashed out so much.
She cashed out so fucking much that she's set for life.
Alright, nice.
2... 3...
Oh my god.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please tell me you at least rinsed the plate with water.
I guess I won't say anything then.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Get rid of the flavor from the old pasta?
That I ate like a couple of hours before?
When she goes to jail, it'd be locked to a...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's crazy is that Crypto is back.
I was not expecting that.
Because there was like a grey... I don't know if NFTs are back, but I know like cryptocurrency is back now.
Why?
I don't know.
Because people are scared about government.
They don't want it to be regulated by the government because cryptocurrency isn't regulated by anything.
Apparently people are like...
who held their money...
You know what they should be doing if they're so scared of the government?
Why can't we go back to the old ways where we just buried gold?
It's more fun too.
It's more fun because if you die to your gold, you can make it like a little treasure hunt every time if you need to pay something.
If they're so scared.
I miss the good old days when people were scared about the government and banks where they would just buy a bunch of gold and then bury it under their bed or something.
Under the floorboards.
Or within the socks.
Because it can double as a weapon too.
We can use it as a weapon and as a paperweight.
And then it can be a nice little fun treasure hunt for all your friends when you die.
Like, imagine having like, you know, a hundred thousand dollars of gold buried around the world and you be like, in your will, you're like, hello friends, if you wanna find my treasure, you gotta figure out this treasure map.
It's like a fun little mini game.
They're all your family and friends.
Oh my god, please.
I just invest my money in vtubers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No, come on.
What do you mean worst in crypt?
Who are you, Timothy McKenzie?
That's right.
That's so smart.
Putting your full name first and last name, Timothy McKenzie.
Mr. McKenzie, does your mom know you're watching a vtuber right now?
How dare you say it's worst in crypto?
That's fucked up.
At least, like, I provide physical things.
Imagine using your whole name as a as a username.
That's right, I'ma google you right now, Mr. Timothy McKenzie.
How many Timothy McKenzie's are out in this world?
There's a lot.
There's an actor named Timothy McKenzie.
Are you an actor?
Are you Labyrinth?
Is this you?
Bro, is this you?
Are you?
It's my baltech handle.
It's not doxy when it's public!
The game is getting to me, yeah.
I swear, that Apex custom that we did, um, we had, like, we spent more time fucking fishing than we did playing the fucking video game.
Oh my god.
JL, thank you for the magenta, super!
Thank you, thank you.
Investing in vtubers have far better returns.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Investing in me gives you so much more.
This is a fact that Doki is a bird.
If anyone argue against it, they are liars.
Thank you for the super chat, one guy, thank you.
Oh my god, I looked at chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tequila, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
If we trace the line of where FlappyDragoon goes, it's like a crypto stock market.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I like how someone was like, I reselled because you docked someone live on stream.
You're like, bro, I fuck with that.
You're just like, oh my god, if I don't, maybe she'll do it.
If I don't resell, maybe she'll do me next.
Wait, unfortunately, I'm already a public persona?
Oh my god, are you fucking famous?
Okay.
Alright, TKF Okay, that's not your real, that's not your real name?
Who the fuck makes their first and last name like...
Wait...
Oh...
I think I actually know what I actually like.
Okay, I'm gonna stop.
Alright.
Zayla, thank you for the five gifted ships, thank you, thank you.
Alright, hold up.
Okay, I'm gonna delete that.
She flew too close to the sun.
All I'm saying, Wait, then why the fuck do you choose this random man's name as your username?
Okay.
Wait, if you're a public persona, are you famous?
Are you a government worker?
Which government?
Can I get advantages over it?
You get used to it?
Wait, who are you?
Who are- Who the fuck are you?
What does that mean?
What does that even mean?
Who is this man?
What does he mean by you get used to it?
It's the IRS.
Oh my god, it's the IRS.
That's so like...
Like, that raises more questions.
Oh my god, please.
Okay.
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Ten...
Eleven...
Twelve...
Thirteen...
Fourteen...
Sixteen...
Twenty -five...
Twenty-six...
Oh my god, I have really good interest rates too.
Every...
65 years, you get 0.01% interest.
Me, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Me, me.
Oh my god.
The myth, the legend, Greg.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Oh my god, there's so many Akasupa!
Thank you so much, guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Please.
Invest in a doki bank.
Not a scam.
Every 65 years, you get 0.01% interest rate back.
Come on, isn't that like a stealer?
Exactly 65 years.
Please.
I wanna break my high score.
I don't understand crypto.
In general.
I don't know.
I feel like, you know...
I don't like having your money in like crypto coin is like...
Like you might get your money back and all that shit, but like...
Like, I don't know.
I feel like...
You know, it's like let's go gambling.
But you're life savings.
Yeah, a lot of them are like rug pulls.
I was watching a video of like this little kid that was scamming like...
Millennials and boomers.
Oh my god, please.
With like made up with like crypto coin and they just made them invest in it and then like he like rug pulls it.
Because they're like, oh my god, we gotta get in on this market.
And then this kid made like $400,000 in crypto.
He hasn't even hit puberty yet.
That's a crazy thing.
Yeah.
Oh, do you make 30k?
I thought you made like 400k.
He did like three times too.
Like damn, like zoomers like...
When I was like that kid, like he hasn't hit puberty yet and he's like scamming the elderly.
Bro, you know what?
I was worried.
You know what?
I was playing fucking playing Pokemon before I realized like it's the same game.
Sorry to all the Pokemon fans out there.
I just have I haven't fucked with Pokemon a long time.
I love like I still love like the designs of some of their Pokemon, but like I'm so bored with Pokemon games.
And also I never got into like I got into like uh I got into like Pokemon cards when I was like really young not like I know like a lot of people like collecting Pokemon cards and stuff.
Um, I never I I like got into it when I was like super young but you know Like when you're super young you're like pretty colors.
That's me.
I never like actually got into Pokemon card collecting.
Um, so like I never like cared about it too like much.
Like the only gacha thing that I actually like is like physical toy gacha, you know?
Like the gachapon machines and like the blind boxes as long as it's cute.
I like that like figure wise.
I just never got into like cards.
Okay Oh my god
I just want to break my record.
I always fly too high like that's like my issue
I'm getting better though Like I sort of ah Every time every time I get a little bit confident.
I get a little bit fucking confident
I think the weirdest part about Pokemon cards is the fact that like Um, they don't put them.
Oh, okay.
There's like several things weird I was like going to like london drugs, which is like a canadian a canadian like marketplace Um where it sells everything and they have like cards as well Like they like now they lock up the pokemon cards because people I guess like people keep like stealing them.
So like um So like they would like Lock they now lock up They lock up pokemon cards because like and that's like the only thing locked like I would see like electronics and everything But they're not locked like they're you know, you can buy kettles you can buy like,
uh Buy like electronics and stuff like very expensive Electronics and everything but like you can grab them whenever but when it comes to pokemon cards Like you got they gotta lock it up into a fucking storage thing And you have to get like an attendant to come over there to grab it for you Yeah,
there's like a huge scalper problem and I feel like you know, there's like that type of problem I know like a lot of people a lot of stores in na they don't limit they don't limit it in japan They do in japan.
It's like you gotta buy like one box or something.
You can only buy like one box and stuff
And like one of my like I was like hanging out with um Some friends and then like they wanted to buy some pokemon cards and they were like, um, and we're like, okay Yeah, we can come with you.
And yeah, I touched grass one time and then I remember like one time I was touching grass with some people Um, they were wanting to buy the specific pokemon card like pokemon card Uh deck or whatever like the classic 151 cards um And then like the guy was like,
oh, sorry, we sold out those were the exact same They were the only boxes we sold out for that type of um Booster pack and I was so confused.
I was like that can happen
Yeah, it's like a super scalp scalp set apparently I almost I almost bought the original the ps5 pro playstation 1 anniversary From a scalper.
I almost did it.
I controlled myself.
I was oh I was this close guys.
You guys have no idea actually, really They know the nostalgia bait tried to nostalgia bait me and it almost worked because I oh my god, i'm weak I was this close.
I was actually this close to buying a playstation 1 20th anniversary skin for the playstation 5 pro because I was like the nostalgia bait actually Almost got me I went by the controller though.
The controller looks so fucking cute
Yeah, I didn't get the pre-order because it was like super limited and well to be fair I forgot when the pre-order date I forgot what the pre-order date was.
I never bothered.
I never I never bothered to check It's sold for like a thousand plus dollars like the scalpers But like I heard the controllers are like you can buy it whenever the controllers are not limited So I might just get the controller then Oh my god, this is why i'm so fucking stupid I hit my head too much on the top of the tree Oh my god,
this is like I don't even hit the bottom I just hit the top
But it reminded me of the the the pikachu the pokemon collaboration with uh With the art museum in paris Van Gogh, right?
Oh, yeah with van Gogh It reminded me of that like the The van Gogh pokemon collaboration And then it was just there was like videos of just like scalpers like fucking um Was just going ham on the merch store It was so bad
Oh, it was in amsterdam, sorry for I was actually in amsterdam not in paris It was such a cool collaboration, too
Oh Uh, anonis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, we're in kingdom hearts.
What would your keyblade look like?
it'll be like It'll be a gun
They'll never the heartless will never expected
It'll look like a key But at the end of it it'll just be like a hole where I just shoot people And then the handle is where I reload Gun blade.
Yeah gun blade but a key so like, you know how like there's like the little The line On the key so like um Okay.
Wait, i'm gonna draw this out.
This is how I see my gun blade.
So like And this is a hole we're okay here and then And then here is and then
And then I reload here this I reload here Reload you can tell where's the reload button is.
All right, i'll show you guys my key Yeah, because I didn't have paint open.
I just I was illustrating it, but you'll understand when I You see it you'll understand All right.
This is what my gun blade would look like.
It looks like a regular key, but like it's a gun I transform There so like so like that's the hole where the bullets come out and then right here Um that third area the random indent here is where you reload your ammo so like you're like reloading and The trigger is where you're holding the key blade so It does look that's the ammo clip right there and then the trigger hand is where you know,
you hold the key Area and then that's where you like pew pew.
It's just like pew pew Oh And then like, you know, the heartless will not expect it they won't expect it They think it's a fucking fighting game Honestly, like I think if I could headshot the heartless like Sora would not have any of these problems
But what about like the keychain oh the keychain It'll be a dragoon Don't keep visualizing out of the dragon next to you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I'm just saying if Sora had a gun he would not be there would be no Roxas
And people like no not Roxas he was the best part Yeah, but not like non Kingdom Hearts 2 when I had to fail a three hours of his fucking tutorial
Everyone I know I have a friend that's so fucking obsessed with him.
Um No, I know I lived through that um Thank you for the five Thank you.
Thank you You're right.
If Sora had a gun there would be no Xehanort Honestly, I still think the funniest thing is that the creator of Kingdom Hearts has to watch like um history of Kingdom Hearts Just to remember what the fuck he did I can't wait for Kingdom Hearts 4 to be bit to be just the city Like he's just Sora is apparently just a fucking normie in the end
Well, you guys didn't know no I talked about it before in a previous stream the creator of Kingdom Hearts literally watches like Like he forgets what happened like he forgets some of the shit that he like made up so like he would like pull up like Kingdom Hearts like YouTube analysis videos like And history videos to be like what the fuck did I do just to like remember what?
Just to make sure it all still connected
No, it is wild it's no longer about like the original concept the Kingdom Hearts was like Final fantasy and like disney characters like a final fantasy slash disney crossover But now there's so many fucking original characters.
Like I don't know what the fuck is going on
Um back, thank you, let's super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Lore wise roxas would still have to happen Since he came for Sora to free Kairi's heart which got trapped before he had the key Thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, but like If he had a gun He didn't have to turn into a heartless To be cut he didn't have to turn into a heartless to get Kairi's heart back You could have just shot the guy
I'm pretty sure he's not like immune to fucking bullets like
There's no way But that's murder where the fuck did the heartless go when they die?
Wait, wait, what the fuck a keyblade was still killing Like that's murder Die it's just they die faster The kingdom hearts
Now it's murder
You should just all have guns give goofy a gun Instead of this weak-ass shield Where do we even get a gun?
It's Final Fantasy!
They all have guns!
Which is surprising, why don't they...
All the characters with guns in Final Fantasy don't show up.
Instead, they're given, like, stupid fucking swords.
They're given melee weapons.
Yeah, but he doesn't use it.
He still uses his stupid sword.
Take that back, Doki.
His gun sword was not stupid.
Yeah, but he doesn't even use the gun part!
I remember playing Kingdom Hearts and he doesn't even use his gun part.
It just goes, like, slash, slash.
I'm like, you have a gun.
Shoot it.
Shoot your...
Nexie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Someone once wrote, Akuroku fanfic for creative writing coursework and got away with it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, don't worry.
I have a friend.
Like, that friend that was super obsessed with Roxas.
I bet they read... I bet they read your fanfic.
I'm...
I'm about to fucking freak out right now.
I never got into Final Fantasy.
I think I told you guys about this before, but, like...
But, like, when Final Fantasy... I got into...
The first Final Fantasy game I played was the X2 one.
The X-2 one.
Where, like... Yeah, I started the worst Final Fantasy game in the series.
And then, you know, I didn't understand anything because apparently that was supposed to be a sequel...
To, like, another Final Fantasy game.
But that was the very first Final Fantasy game I bought.
So, like, I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
Because I started off with a fucking sequel.
And then I was really young, too, so I was, like, even more confused.
And so... So... Yeah.
Because, like, it just came out.
And then, like, I was like, ooh, Final Fantasy.
I heard stuff about it.
I was, like, really young.
And I was like, ooh, I heard stuff about this game.
And I was really, really fucking young.
So, like, I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
And I also did not understand what the fuck was going on.
And then, like... And then I, you know, I didn't like it.
So I was just like, you know what?
Final Fantasy isn't for me.
And then, I was like... And then, like, years passed.
And I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna give Final Fantasy another try.
And you know what Final Fantasy game it was when I decided that?
It was the one with lightning.
So...
I was like, alright.
Let's try.
Let's try to, like, let's try that.
It's a new game.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, guys, I need to lock in.
50.
Oh my god.
I got 50, though.
I got 50.
Okay.
Okay, wait, no.
Give Sora a gun.
There you go.
Give Sora...
Alright, I was so locked in.
I was so fucking locked in there.
Oh yeah, but anyway.
So I was like, I'm gonna give it another try.
So it was the lightning.
The game with lightning in it.
And then, I didn't like it that much either.
Cause I was like, I don't know, apparently a lot of people didn't like it.
So like, I chose the second wrong game to get into.
And then, so then I never gave Final Fantasy a shot after that.
I was just like, yeah, like...
I was literally like, yeah.
I guess, and then that's why I never got into it.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If only SmallDoki bought FFX instead of FFX2, what would've happened?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Avelia, thank you for the five gifted ships.
You know, I did say, I'm gonna break my record before I call it.
Alright, I know this is a short stream, guys.
I know it was a short stream.
But I did do an earlier stream today.
And I have a lot of work to do behind the scenes today.
So I gotta work on that.
And I'm gonna eat my food.
I'm hungry.
Hey guys, for the developers, that was really fun.
Thank you to the team that made Flappy Dragoon.
I would love to work with you guys on improving this in the future.
If the dev team is open for it.
I would love to like, maybe perhaps refine it more.
And have a Steam release to it.
Anton, thank you for the AkaSupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, before you head out, can you try clicking the question on the main menu?
Sure, what is it?
Hello, thanks for playing our game.
This is made as a team experience exercise for something bigger.
A more action oriented...
Oh, what?
We could use your house.
Wait, there's more?
Oh my god, that's so...
Wait, you guys are making more?
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, Dragoons.
It really means so much.
Excellent, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As one of those, I'm so happy for my Oshi to play our game with Shaking my Solid Knees.
I recommend also trying Doki Flat by Rice Snack.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'll be down to try to avoid games from you guys.
I really love all your creativity.
And like, all the effort you guys made into this.
Especially like, you know, it's really hard to make a video game.
So, it's actually so cool.
Guys, thank you guys so much.
Also, you guys are such a great fan base.
If you guys didn't know, apparently you can still vote.
Apparently, the VTuber Awards voting is still ongoing.
So like, oh wait, never mind, they just closed it.
JK.
JK, I was gonna say, vote for yourself, but they just closed it.
So like, never mind.
We'll see who wins then.
We'll see who wins.
Anyway guys, I'm gonna head off now.
Thank you everybody for coming.
As always everyone, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.